quoi de mieux qu'un bon casse-croûte
avec des aliments locaux pour débuter
cette journée
300 marmailles du CP au lycée venu de
toute l'île ont participé à ce concours
littéraire qui vise à mettre en valeur
la langue créole tous fiers d'être
récompensé de plus en plus nous on est
vraiment perdu
mais voilà avec ce
que
ce
de plus en plus ils mettent la réunion
les mettre le créole réunionnais le vrai
créole réunion en l'air
créole une langue enfantée dans la
douleur comme nous le rappelle ces
écoliers c'est la langue maternelle de
la Réunion donc c'est un petit peu
important
le temps de la préserver cette langue
oui c'est important ben c'est comme
c'est comme pour le français c'est
important de la conserver parce que
c'est la langue c'est une langue bah
d'un pays et ben toutes les langues ont
le droit d'être connu donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut la conserver
les élèves ont travaillé pendant trois
mois pour concevoir un texte et le
clamer ou le mettre en chanson Mama
l'imagination donc au contraire c'est
notre
caseras c'est de canaliser
réunis à tout ça pour vous mettre les
autres imagination en l'écrit je suis
papier
aussi parce que l'écrit le fond de cœur
va rester mais malgré un certain
engouement le créole à l'école reste
encore pour les organisateurs de ce
concours une bataille à mener
les plus faciles de faire un concours en
créole comme un cours en créole dans
l'école les plus compliqués parce que
même les parents ils vont sa
différemment de ce côté là mais les
vrais que c'est une façon de montrer que
nous peut causes créoles partout en
hiver sans oublier que ne nous doit
apprendre le français tout ça là et tout
ça il fonctionne bien
c'est avec leur maloya sur un texte qui
parle du pirate labuse que les cinquième
du collège plateau de Saint-Louis ont
remporté le premier prix collège de
cette troisième édition du Prix honoré
pour l'école
[Musique]